Hey everybody, you're listening to Smart List hosted by Jason Bateman, Will Arnett, and myself, Sean Hayes. I know, I wish my voice was more masculine too. This show is about learning through laughter in the brains of people around the world who are far smarter than us three idiots. And each week, one of us brings on a guest who the other two don't know about. So with that, let's jump into the Smart List rocket ship and let's blast off into the universe together. Ooh, I think I just turned myself on. Smart List Smart List
大家好，你们正在收听由杰森·贝特曼、威尔·阿奈特以及我本人肖恩·海斯主持的《聪明清单》。我知道，我也希望我的声音能更有男人味一点。这个节目旨在通过笑声，去了解世界上那些比我们三个笨蛋聪明得多的人的大脑。每周，我们中的一个人会邀请一位另外两人都不知道的嘉宾。那么，让我们一起登上《聪明清单》的火箭，一起向宇宙发射吧。噢，我觉得我刚才把自己给点燃了。《聪明清单》《聪明清单》
Smart List Do you guys still game? Like, are you gamers? Yeah. Uh-uh. You aren't? Absolutely not. Because Will, you tried to get me gaming like 75 years ago and I like played one round with you. Such a little, many, many years ago and I was like, I'm out. I can't figure it out. But Scotty is obsessed with Mario Kart like on his phone.
《聪明清单》你们平时还玩游戏吗？比方说，你们是游戏玩家吗？对。呃-呃。你们不是？绝对不是。因为威尔，你大概在75年前就想拉我入坑，然后我好像跟你玩了一局。那是好久好久以前的事了，当时我就想：我不玩了。我搞不懂。不过斯科蒂对手机上的《马里奥赛车》简直入了迷。
Wisconsin listener, that is Sean's husband. Yeah, so that's been Scotty. Right. Okay. So listen, I recorded him. This is just like a half hour ago. Getting really upset at the Mario Kart. What are you supposed to do in the game? I said that all I'm supposed to do is to hit these big, huge, giant mushrooms while I'm driving on the course and I keep missing all of them. How does that make you feel? Pretty upset because I'm better than that.
威斯康星州的听众朋友们，那就是肖恩的丈夫。对，所以一直是斯科蒂在玩。没错。好吧。听着，我录下了他的一段视频。就在大概半小时前。他玩《马里奥赛车》气得够呛。你在这游戏里到底是该干嘛的？我说我唯一该做的就是在赛道上开车时撞那些又大又巨型的蘑菇，可我却一直在错过它们。这让你感觉怎么样？气死我了，因为我明明水平比这高。
Wow. And here's the disturbing part is that he didn't know you were recording him. So that's the real, that's your real world that you're living in. That kind of hostility. And I love how Kurt, he got with, I said that. Yeah, you're dealing with a real short fuse and a guy who doesn't like employment clearly, right? This middle of the day. He was working all day actually.
哇。而让人不安的部分是，他根本不知道你在录音。所以这就是你生活的真实世界。那种敌意。我喜欢库尔特对我说的那句话，当我提到这个时。是的，你面对的是一个脾气非常急躁的家伙，而且显然是个不喜欢有工作的人，对吧？这大白天天的。其实他一整天都在工作。
But he was, I was just tickled about how upset he gets at this little children's game. Sean and I went on a trip to Istanbul. We've been on a couple of vacays. Jason, I remember you got real hurt about it before. That's why I'm bringing it up again. The point is the whole way there and back and that from LA to Istanbul is like a 13 hour flight or something. Sean played Candy Crush both ways. Yeah.
但他就是……我只是觉得好笑，他居然能为一个儿童小游戏气成这样。肖恩和我去伊斯坦布尔旅行过。我们一起度过好几次假了。杰森，我记得你以前因为这事挺受伤的。所以我才又把它提出来。重点是，去的那一路、回的那一路，从洛杉矶到伊斯坦布尔得飞个13小时左右吧。肖恩来回程都在玩《糖果传奇》。对。
Oh, sure. And I slept the whole way. I woke up right before we were landing and stuff and Sean was just up. So we do the things we're both good at. I'm good at strategy and you're good at sleeping. All right. So first of all, do you guys get, are you more relaxed when you are hosting the guest or are you more relaxed when you're in the blind?
噢，当然。而我一路都在睡觉。快降落的时候我才醒来，然后肖恩还醒着。所以我们都在做自己擅长的事。我擅长策略，而你擅长睡觉。好吧。首先，各位，当你们采访嘉宾时会更放松，还是当你们什么都不知道（盲选）时更放松？
Like you two guys are today because today's my guest. In the blind. Much more relaxed. You don't get anxiety that like, what if the person that is the guest is somebody that either you're not interested in or you know nothing about and you don't know what to ask? Which gives you more stress? I think it's kind of exciting. It's exciting.
就像你们俩今天这样，因为今天是我的嘉宾。在盲选时。放松得多。你不会感到焦虑吗？万一那个嘉宾是你根本不感兴趣的，或者你对Ta一无所知、根本不知道该问什么呢？哪个给你的压力更大？我觉得这挺刺激的。很刺激。
Except both are exciting. I like meeting people that we all know. So you're excited right now is what you're saying? I'm very excited. I'm so excited that I'm not willing to stand up. Oh, well, temper that temper that because this is not, this is not one of our more attractive guests. It's a good thing that a listener can't see this person. They, they're certainly not known for their looks or their talent or kindness.
不过两种都很刺激。我喜欢见我们大家都认识的人。所以你现在很兴奋，你是这个意思吧？我非常兴奋。我兴奋得都不想站起来了。哦，好吧，收敛点，收敛点，因为这位可不是、可不是我们那些比较有吸引力的嘉宾之一。听众看不到这个人，这倒是一件好事。Ta们可绝对不是靠外表、才华或善良出名的。
But if you were a fan of, let's say projects like Mac and me, or if you're a kitschy horror fan, you loved her in leprechaun. Ladies and gentlemen. By the way, I am a fan of leprechaun. Well, then you should be just tickled. Stay seated, Sean. Don't stand up and show her. No way. Ladies and gentlemen, Jennifer Aniston.
但如果你喜欢，比方说像《外星人麦克》这样的项目，或者如果你是个恶趣味恐怖片粉丝，你就会爱死她在《小妖精》里的表现了。女士们先生们。顺便说一句，我确实是《小妖精》的粉丝。好吧，那你就该乐开花了。坐好，肖恩。别站起来展示她。没门。女士们先生们，詹妮弗·安妮斯顿。
No. Hi, Jen. No. Wow. You know what? First of all, let me just say, Jen, you're gorgeous. Jason, even in jest, don't ever say that about a lady. She's gorgeous.
不。嗨，珍。不。哇。你知道吗？首先，我要说，珍，你太美了。杰森，哪怕是开玩笑，也永远不要对一位女士这么说。她美极了。
You're terrific, Jen. So I take. God bless. Please, Jason, pretend. Dare you. Poor Jen. She's tough to look at. Can you turn your camera off, please?
你太棒了，珍。所以……上帝保佑。拜访啦，杰森，装装样子。借你个胆。可怜的珍。她长得真让人没眼看。请把你的摄像头关掉，好吗？
Yes. Hold on. No. Let me do that. One of the more. Are you, are you still, how many years were you the most beautiful people in the world? Oh, please. It must be.
好的。等等。不。让我来弄。其中一个更……你是不是、是不是依然……你连续多少年被评为世界上最美丽的人？哦，拜访啦。一定……
I did 10 years. I want to know what you're eating. What is that right there? It's Jason Bateman's favorite. Is that the chopped salad? Oh, my God. Oh, that's so nice. It might have some feta cheese in there.
我连续10年。我想知道你平时都吃些什么。那是什么东西？那是杰森·贝特曼的最爱。那是切碎沙拉吗？哦，天哪。哦，太棒了。里面可能还有些羊乳酪吧？
You got the chicken in that? Oh, yeah. Yeah. And the Aniston dressing? Yeah. God, it's so good. Got it all, babe. By the way, every time I've been to your house, you're eating a chopped salad.
你里面加了鸡肉吗？哦，对。对。还有安妮斯顿秘制沙拉酱？对。天哪，太好吃了。全都有，宝贝。顺便说一句，我每次去你家，你都在吃切碎沙拉。
I know. Every single time I'm eating a chopped salad. Yeah. There's always a chopped salad ready in case you want. Yes, that's what I'm saying. Because I've had it many times. Here's one of the things. And I brought this up the other day that Jason loves to, as we know, he loves to eat almonds.
我知道。每次去我都在吃切碎沙拉。对。家里总是备着一份切碎沙拉，以防你想吃。对，这就是我想说的。因为我吃过好多次了。这里有一件事。我前几天还提到过这个，杰森最喜欢吃——如我们所知，他喜欢吃杏仁。
And he's always like picking at nuts and whatever. And whatever Amanda lets him eat. Yeah. Just like little berries off the ground and stuff. But when he comes to your house, he loves eating your jars of candy. Because for some reason he feels like he didn't buy it so it doesn't count. Right. So he stands next to the M&Ms and he hammers them.
他总是像个松鼠一样挑坚果吃，或者随便吃点什么。吃阿曼达允许他吃的任何东西。对。就像地上掉的小浆果之类的。但每当他去你家时，他最喜欢吃你罐子里的糖果。因为出于某种原因，他觉得这不是他买的，所以就不算吃。对吧。于是他就站在M&M's豆罐子旁边，疯狂猛塞。
And I'm like, what are you doing, dude? I just get so excited that there's jars of candy. I don't know if I've ever seen you hammer the M&Ms like that. I'm sneaky with it. Kid who escaped from Fat Camp. He's just there. I follow my daughters in there and we just take down a whole bunch of it. You know, the word for his kids, they'd believe, I think all of your kids actually, I don't know if your, well, your kids ever bought it, but that there's a camera looking at the candy jars.
我就想：老兄，你在干嘛呢？我就是太兴奋了，一看到有罐装糖果。我都不知道自己有没有见过你那样疯狂猛塞M&M's豆。我吃得很隐蔽。就像从减肥夏令营逃出来的小孩。他就站在那儿。我跟着我的女儿们走进去，然后我们一起把一大堆糖果横扫一空。你知道大家对他孩子的评价吗，他们会相信——我觉得其实你所有的孩子都会相信，我不知道你的、好吧，你的孩子们有没有买过账——那就是糖果罐旁边有个摄像头在盯着。
So that they are terrified to actually steal candy without their mother or father knowing. That's smart. And it works. Maple's the only believer actually. Yeah. By the way, like the Bateman girls are afraid of Jason. I mean, let's be honest, right? I do enjoy playing good cop.
所以他们吓得根本不敢在父母不知情的情况下偷糖果。这很聪明。而且管用。枫叶其实是唯一的信徒。对。顺便说一句，贝特曼家的女孩们其实挺怕杰森的。我是说，老实说，对吧？我确实很享受扮演好警察。
Well, I think Amanda and I are pretty good at switching off back and forth between good cop, bad cop. I would ask that to the group. What would you say about that? What about you and Amanda? No, about like, do I come across and Jen, this is your interview, we're going to get to you in a second. I want you to tell me. I'm trying to pull up my script for Mack and me just to see. Yeah.
好吧，我觉得我和阿曼达在好警察和坏警察之间来回切换得挺好的。我想问问大家。你们对此怎么看？你和阿曼达呢？不，我是说，我给人的感觉是——珍，今天是你的采访，我们一会儿就聊到你。我想听你说。我正试图调出我的《外星人麦克》剧本来看看。对。
Oh God. It was so good. That was your first film, right? Please. Come on. 1987. Yeah. Listen.
哦，天哪。太棒了。那是你的第一部电影，对吧？拜托。得了吧。1987年。对。听着。
I sat on a blanket in the background. Is that in my Wikipedia page? Yeah. I am the worst interview in the world. It's all Wikipedia for me. They're just conversation starters. Oh my God. But wait, but let's wrap me up for one second.
我坐在背景里的一条毯子上。这写在我的维基百科页面上吗？对。我是世界上最烂的采访对象。对我来说全靠维基百科。那些只是开启对话的引子。哦，天哪。不过等等，让我自己总结一下，就一秒钟。
Sure. Of course. We'd love to wrap you. Let's wrap you up in a tiny bow. You were wrapped about 10 years ago, Bates. Do I strike you as a disciplinarian or permissive? I would like to answer that. I think Amanda, because she's a strong, incredibly wonderful woman.
当然。当然。我们很乐意把你包裹起来。你大概在10年前就被包裹起来了，贝茨。你觉得我给人的印象是严厉型的还是放任型的？我想回答这个问题。我觉得阿曼达，因为她是一个坚强、极其出色的女性。
I just assume she's the enforcer. You're the enabler. Yup. Because you're very sweet. I worry about Amanda. I sometimes feel like what's going to end up taking her life is she's going to one time just roll her eyes into the back of her head and they're never going to come back. It's going to be an eye rolling incident.
我直接就觉得她是那个执行纪律的人。而你则是那个纵容者。没错。因为你人太好了。我很担心阿曼达。有时我觉得，最终可能会要了她命的事，是她某次会把双眼翻到脑后，然后就再也翻不回来了。那将会是一次翻白眼事故。
And that's what's going to finally take her. All right. All right. Guys, we have Jennifer Aniston. Come on now. I know. Let's tighten it up. All right.
而这最终会要了她的命。好了。好了。伙计们，我们请到了詹妮弗·安妮斯顿。快说点正经的吧。我知道。让我们收一收。好吧。
Listen. Now let me tell you what Wikipedia has yielded here. Hold on. Hold on. Go ahead. Well, congratulations on your baby, Willie. Thanks, Jen. Thanks.
听着。现在让我告诉你维基百科都搜出了什么。等一下。等一下。说吧。祝贺你喜得贵子，威利。谢谢，珍。谢谢。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's doing great. That's amazing. I congratulated him on that he made one. Sean, you haven't done anything. Okay. Hi, Sean. Hi, honey.
对，对，对。他现在挺好的。太棒了。我祝贺他终于生了一个。肖恩，你可什么都没做。好吧。嗨，肖恩。嗨，亲爱的。
How are you? Good. How are you doing? Good. I'm a listener and I don't know you. Like what would I ask you if we, right? I know. And so when I'm over your house, there's, it's so warm and friendly and it feels like home
你好吗？很好。你过得怎么样？很好。我是个听友，我根本不认识你。如果我们在……我该问你什么呢？我懂。所以当我在你家时，那里是如此温馨友好，感觉就像家一样。
and that sounds really cheesy to say it, but it feels like, yeah, this is, it's so easy. Like you live there. Yeah. Absolutely. I could totally live there. Yeah. So I want to know like when you have gatherings like that is, is that fulfilled something in you that you like, because you don't have kids.
这么说听起来可能有点老套，但感觉确实是……这就好象，太自在了。就像你本来就住在那儿一样。对。绝对的。我完全可以住在那里。对。所以我想知道，当你们举办这种聚会时，这是否满足了你内心的某种需求，因为你没有孩子？
It's like, because I do that too sometimes. I love to entertain. Yes. And I love to light fires whilst entertaining. You're being very modest and Sean is making a point which Jason will concur with because he spends even more time there with, with you, but I've spent a lot of time at your house as well. You're very warm and you do love to entertain.
就好像……因为有时我也会这样。我喜欢招待客人。是的。而且我喜欢在招待客人的时候点起篝火。你太谦虚了，肖恩正在阐述一个观点，杰森也会对此表示赞同，因为他和你们在一起的时间甚至比你还多，不过我在你家也待过很多时间。你非常热情，而且你确实很喜欢招待客人。
You love having people over. And you're very maternal. You're like instinctually maternal. And your friends are like family and you have a lot of parties around a lot of holidays and you get a lot of people together. And I agree with Sean. It's always a really good feeling being there. You always feel very welcome.
你喜欢家里宾客盈门。而且你很有母性。你骨子里就有一种母性的本能。你的朋友们就像家人一样，你在很多节日里都会办很多派对，你会把很多人聚在一起。我同意肖恩的看法。在那里总是感觉非常好。你总是会感到非常受欢迎。
There are a lot of laughs. Everything's about laughing and having a good time. Yeah. And I've never left there being like, fuck those guys. Like, you know what I mean? It's always been, I mean about Bateman. Horrible. About Jason for sure, cause he always leaves early before Amanda as we know.
有很多欢笑。一切都是为了欢笑和度过一段美好的时光。是的。而且我从来没有离开时说过“去他妈的那些家伙”这种话。就像，你知道我的意思吗？一直以来，我是指关于贝特曼。太糟糕了。肯定是指杰森，因为正如我们所知，他总是比阿曼达早走。
I like to clear out. Can we just bust you on that? Can we blow up your spot? Jason likes to leave places about 90 minutes earlier than his wife. Well, that's why we take two cars to Jen's often. Often we take two cars. Yeah. Because unless you're on vacation with him, then he can't leave you.
我喜欢早点撤。我们能直接揭你的短吗？能拆穿你的老底吗？杰森喜欢比他妻子早大约90分钟离开聚会。嗯，这就是为什么我们去珍家时经常开两辆车。我们经常开两辆车。对。除非你是跟他一起去度假，那他就没办法甩掉你了。
Then we're, then we're just stuck with him. No, but you pull some good late nights when we're, I mean late night, what midnight? That's a pretty late night. But it is true, Jen. You have so many friends and just so many, and you have so many good friends. You don't have just a lot of like sort of haphazard friends. No. You have really close relationships with people, a lot of one-on-one relationships.
那我们就只能、只能被他死死缠住了。不，不过当我们聚会时，你确实也会熬到挺晚的，我是说晚到什么时候？半夜？那已经挺晚了。但这是真的，珍。你有那么多的朋友，有那么多、那么多好朋友。你可不仅仅只有一大群那种萍水相逢的泛泛之交。没有。你和人们有着真正亲密的关系，很多都是一对一的深交。
You're good to a lot of people. You're very sweet. And it's a testament to somebody about how the quality of their friends and that you have really great friends. Would you guys agree? Yes, I would agree. I would even agree with that. I don't mean that.
你对很多人都很好。你非常温柔。这也证明了一个人的朋友质量有多高，而你确实拥有非常棒的朋友。大家同意吗？是的，我同意。我甚至也同意这一点。我不是在自夸。我是说，我是。好吧，你确实是。我觉得这其实是在给威尔打广告，夸他是个好朋友，是个极好的……欢迎来到本期播客。珍，你小时候家里经常办派对吗？那里是不是总是充满了养育和关爱，就像是一个有趣、温馨、能请一大群……
I'm not complimenting myself. I mean, I am. Well, you are. I think this is really a plug for Will and being a great friend and being a really good God. Welcome to the podcast. Jen, did you grow up in a house that had a lot of entertaining going on? And was it always sort of nurturing and kind of like a fun, warm place to have a bunch
朋友来做客的地方？还是说这完全是你个人的风格，是你人生某个特定阶段的产物？那段时期我的父母，当时我们搬到了纽约市，在我父亲经历了一段时间的挣扎之后，他终于上了一部肥皂剧，你知道的，我们当时……我父亲并没有真正取得他想要的成功。所以后来我们搬到了希腊，然后他试图在那里读医学院。你在希腊住了多久？
of friends over? Or is that something that is wholly yours and came as a result of a particular period in your life? A period of time where my parents, when we had moved to New York City and my dad was on a soap opera after we'd kind of been struggling for a while, you know, we were, my dad didn't really hit it the way he wanted to. So then we moved to Greece and then he was trying to go to medical school there. How long did you live in Greece?
我在希腊住了一年。哇。我在雅典住了六个月，然后在克里特岛住了六个月。哇。我不知道这件事。哇。真的吗？这没写在我的维基百科页面上。
I lived in Greece for a year. Wow. I lived in Athens for six months and then Crete for six months. Wow. I didn't know that. Wow. Really? It's not on my wiki page.
没有。也许它在……《跳在跳棋格拉维斯上》。找到了。第六页。找到了。找到了。希腊。
No. Maybe it's on the... Dancing on Checker's Gravis. There it is. Page six. There it is. There it is. Greece.
哦，瞧瞧你。哦，我不知道你还会钓鱼。这是一张你拉起龙虾笼的绝佳照片。对。不。不，去找找羊的照片。找找我。里面应该有一张我给羊挤奶的照片。
Oh, look at you. Oh, I didn't know you fish. It's a great picture of you pulling up a lobster trap. Yeah. No. No, look for the sheep. Look for me. There should be one of me milking a sheep.
我太喜欢你爸爸说的那句“去他妈的演艺事业，我们要去希腊，我要去当医生”了。对。是不是很疯狂？那些疯狂的希腊人。好吧，那并没有发生。所以后来他……他搬回了纽约。
I love that your dad said, fuck it to the acting business. We're going to Greece and I'm becoming a doctor. Yeah. Isn't that crazy? Those crazy Greeks. Well, that didn't happen. So then he... He'd go back to New York.
他把我们搬到了纽约。所以我们最初是在加州，在这里出生，谢尔曼奥克斯，斯特恩大道，就在卡萨维加的拐角处。还记得我们聊过那个吗。哦，对。我喜欢那个。对。然后我们搬家了，然后我们去了希腊，接着他在一部肥皂剧《生活的爱》里找到了一份工作。
He moves us to New York. So we'd start out in California, born here, Sherman Oaks, Stern Avenue, right around the corner from Casa Vega. Remember we talked about that. Oh, yeah. I love that. Yeah. And then we moved and then we went to Greece and then he got a job on a soap opera, Love
其余的就成了历史的开端。对。他在那部肥皂剧里演了多久？他在那部肥皂剧里，我想说大概有五年吧，克里斯托弗·里夫在那部剧里演他的儿子。所以他们会办扑克牌派对。他们会有扑克之夜，总能听到那种欢笑声，他们把我哄上床睡觉，而我总是会从卧室爬出来，顺着走廊，只是为了在拐角处偷看一眼，看着所有这些大人物光鲜亮丽的样子，听到冰块碰撞声、杯子叮当声、笑声，哈哈大笑。我的童年也非常相似。对。所以那种……我想我当时就觉得，然后这一切都崩溃了，家庭破裂了。顺便说一句，我也是。
of Life. And the rest was the beginning of history. Yeah. How long was he on that soap opera for? He was on that soap, I want to say for maybe five years and Christopher Reeves played his son on that show. So they would have poker parties. They would have poker nights and there was always that sound of laughter and they'd put
所以是的，我仍然在试图重现我生活中那些快乐的时刻。这就是这一切的重点吗？你是想把我弄哭吗？你很感激自己有过快乐的一天。你很感激自己曾有过那么一天。所以种子就这样种下了：成年人是会招待客人的。我喜欢这样。好吧。对。
me to bed and I would kind of always crawl out of the bedroom, down the hall to just sort of peek around the corner and just watch all these people being fabulous and hearing like ices and clanking and glasses and laughing and la-ha-ha. I grew up very similarly. Yeah. So that sort of, I guess I kind of thought, and then it all crumbled and the family broke apart. By the way, same.
挺好的。他们很有趣。他们度过了一段美好的时光。这里让我感兴趣的另一件事是，我要直接跳过《老朋友》时期，直接进入紧随《老朋友》之后、并在96年重返电影界之前的那个四年间歇期。我没记错吧？哦，你曾是个电影……
So yes, I'm still trying to recreate those happy moments in my life. Is this the point of this whole thing is you're trying to make me cry? You thankful you had a happy day. You thankful you had one day. So the seed was planted that adults entertain. I like that. All right. Yeah.
你是个电影女演员吗？什么？她当然是。哦。你都做了什么？我在《老朋友》之后和开始拍电影之前，经历了一个四年的空窗期。是这样吗？绝对不是。
It was nice. They have fun. They were having a good time. One of the other things that interested me here, I'm going to skip right over friends and I'm going to go to the four-year hiatus that followed friends and preceded your return to film work in 96. So have this right? Oh, you were a film.
没有？那是错的。杰森。这东西是谁写的？好吧，这是你写的吗？姓氏叫维基百科。我不知道他的名字。好吧，这位“百科”先生需要补充点维基常识。
Are you a film actress? What? She sure is. Oh. What did you do? I did a four-year gap after friends and before you started film work. Is that right? Absolutely not.
好吧。关于这个我最喜欢的部分是，在你回答之前，珍，我只想打断一下，因为我想让你知道，威斯康星州的那位听友，在这之后，珍一定会去找阿曼达说：“杰森问了我这么个蠢问题，他甚至……他还问我我是不是经历了一个四年的空窗期——而你完全有权这么做——然后阿曼达就会说：‘杰森，搞什么鬼？你竟然问她这个，你对珍说她有个四年空窗期？’然后杰森就要挨骂了。”
No? That is incorrect. Jason. Who wrote this thing? Well, did you write this? The last name is Wikipedia. I do not know his first name. Well, Mr.Pedia needs some wiki.
而你活该挨揍。我想知道这是不是故意的。你是想，比如说，回希腊呆四年什么的，把状态找回来吗？这就回到了我曾经非常喜欢的那个播客，你们聊到所有镜子都被竖起来，以及杰森问这个问题花了多长时间。看，这就是为什么我们叫《聪明清单》。我可不是个聪明人。我不是个出色的采访者。
All right. Here's my favorite part about this. Before you answer, Jen, I just want to cut off because I want you to know that listener in Wisconsin that right after this, Jen's going to go and say to Amanda, like, Jason asked me this stupid question and he didn't even, and he asked me if I took a four-year gap, which you should, you were well within your right, and then Amanda's going to go, Jason, what the fuck? You asked her and you said this, Jen, a four-year gap, and Jason is going to get it.
那不是真的。不，我不是。我挺邪门的。好吧，现在，你真的很……你正在……我们现在有点过分了，不过——顺便说一句，我是这个播客的超级粉丝。我能这么说吗？得了吧。好吧，我们是你的粉丝。
And you deserve to be smashed. I wanted to know what is it on purpose. You want to, like, go back to Greece for four years or something, get it back. This is where, this is now goes back to the podcast that I loved so much where you talked about all the mirrors being put up and the amount of time it took Jason to ask the question. Well, see, that's why we call it smart list. I'm not a smart guy. I'm not a great interviewer.
好吧，这会儿可不是在讨论我。其实是的。这正是关于你，以及你们所有人的采访水平有多高，我真的非常享受。现在，我花了……让我向你解释一下，因为你在我的第一部电影里演过，那是在《老朋友》之前，叫做……《小妖精》？《分手男女》。《分手男女》是《老朋友》之后的第一部电影？
That's not true. No, I'm not. I'm wicked. Well, right now, you're really, you're, this is, we're pushing it right now, but, but I've been, by the way, a huge fan of this podcast. Can I just say that? Come on. Well, we're a fan of yours.
是的。好吧。一旦《老朋友》拍完，我们立刻就去了芝加哥，还记得吗？你当时在那部电影里。我确实记得我演了那部电影。我太喜欢那部电影了。那是一部伟大的电影。所以你拍所有那些电影都是在拍《老朋友》期间拍的，所有那些其他的电影，比如……
Well, that's just not about me right now. It is, actually. This is about you and how good of an interviewer all of you are, and I've enjoyed it thoroughly. Now, I took, let me explain to you, because you were in my first movie that preceded Friends, which was called. Leprechaun? The Breakup. The Breakup was the first film after Friends?
我不知道。《小妖精》和《外星人麦克》？没有。好吧，我们别再提那两部电影了。行。那些是……不，就像《冒牌天神》和所有其他那些电影。对，那是在《老朋友》拍摄期间。
Yes. All right. Once Friends completed, we rolled right into Chicago, remember? And you were in, you were in that film. I do remember being in that film. I loved that film. That was a great film. So you made all of those movies while you were on Friends, all those other movies, like,
哇。你从来没停下来休息过。我没有。而且我很喜欢这样。对。对。我真的很享受工作。那现在呢？
I don't know. Leprechaun and Mcamey? No. Okay, let's just stop, just stop talking about those two movies. Okay. Those were. No, like Bruce Almighty and all those other movies. Yes, that was during Friends.
好吧，我经历了一段奇怪的……你知道的，伙计们，我最近其实都没怎么离开过家。我不知道你们怎么样。发生什么了？我最近一直没工作。这非常奇怪。等一下。是因为大流行和这段闲暇时间吗？你……你很享受这种被迫停工的休息，还是说你快要疯了、宁愿去工作？
Wow. You just never took a break. I didn't. And I liked it. Yeah. Yeah. I really enjoy working. What about now?
我必须说，我真的很享受这段休息，我有点……如果有人说：“不，你实际上不能去上班了，你只能待在家里。”那感觉就像过生日一样开心。但确实，会有一些有趣的情绪起伏时刻，你会突然感到焦虑，当然这是因为你看了新闻，或者你看到了世界上正在发生的事情，那绝对是毁灭性的、无法想象的。是的，过了一会儿我不得不把它关掉。你必须这么做，但是……
Well, I've been on this weird, you know, guys, I haven't really left the house lately. I don't know about you guys. What happened? I have not been working lately. It's very strange. Wait a minute. That because of the pandemic and because of the downtime, did you, is that a thing that you enjoy being forced upon you, the break, or are you like going crazy and rather work?
而且那种无力感也很强，对吧？就像他们要求我们通过保持消极来提供帮助一样。待在家里是你唯一能做的事。这就像是，好吧，如果我要出门，我就会戴口罩，这就是全部——我的意思是，我看到所有人都在为了拯救这些生命而疯狂努力，这感觉就像是：哇。看看他们。这很不公平。我知道。
I really leaned into the break, I have to say, I kind of, if someone says, no, you actually cannot go to work and you just have to stay home. That's like a happy birthday. But yeah, there have been these interesting ups and downs of moments where you just like feel this anxiety and of course it's because you've watched the news or you see what's going on in the world and it is absolutely devastating and unthinkable. Yeah, I had to turn it off after a while. You have to, but...
但我觉得在这一点上，由于某种奇怪的运气——因为你别无选择——最终，比如说像杰森，最终发生了一些好事，就像“化逆境为美德”一样，在你的情况里，你现在的“无能”变得非常有价值。对。无能是有价值的。是的。对。
And it also feels so impotent to help, right? Like they're asking us to help by being passive. Stay in your house is the best thing you can do. And it's like, okay, if I do go out, I wear a mask, like that's all, I mean, I see all these people working so hard to save all these lives and everything, it's like, wow. And look at them. It feels unfair. I know.
对。你发现这是一个巨大的资产吗？好吧。或者你可以从中吸取教训。对。不，至少现在，我感觉没那么糟糕了。现在所有人都和我坐同一条船了。觉得这个怎么样？
But I kind of feel like at this point that weirdly just sort of by luck because you have to that finally, like Jason, for instance, that finally something good is happening with like make a virtue out of necessity, like in your case, your impotence now is really valuable. Yeah. It's valuable to be impotent. Yes. Yeah.
你离退出这个行业最近的一次是什么时候？这个行业？对。好问题。这个行业？对。对。哦，这倒挺有意思。
Yeah. Are you finding that as a big asset? All right. Or you can learn from it. Yeah. No, finally it's, I don't feel quite as bad. Everyone's in the same boat as me now. How about this?
我不知道，哦，我不得不说，过去两年里这个想法确实在我的脑海中闪现过，这以前可从来没有过。真的？为什么会这样？因为你觉得心满意足了？不是的。还是说在你开始拍《早间秀》之前？在《早间秀》之前。
How about what's the closest you ever got to quitting? The business? Yeah. Great question. The business? Yeah. Yeah. Oh, that's good.
那是在我完成了一份工作之后，当时我想：哇，那可真够呛。把我整个人都榨干了。我不知道这到底是不是我感兴趣的。然后我就有了一种幻想，想着如果直接……你当时是遇到了某种创作瓶颈，还是说更像是跟你合作的人有关，或者仅仅是觉得……一切都受够了？那是一个没有做好准备的项目，你知道的，我们都曾参与过那种项目，然后你总是会说：再也不了，绝对再也不了。
I don't, oh, I would have to say the last two years that has crossed my mind, which it never did before. Really? Why is that? Because you feel satisfied? No. Or before you started the morning show, you mean? Before the morning show.
我现在就正参与着这样一个项目。我绝不再把开机日期定得那么仓促了。对，对。对。缺乏组织。剧本还没准备好。然后你就被困在那里三个月。
It was after a job I had completed and I was like, whoa, that was really, that sucked. The life out of me. And I don't know if this is what interests me. And I had this fantasy of just sort of, what if you just, you know. Was it a creative sort of wall that you hit or was it more about like the people you were working with or was it just sort of like over it all? It was an unprepared project, you know, that was, we've all been a part of them and you always say, I'll never again, never again.
被困住了。对。对。或者差不多这样。这就是为什么我总是敦促你去尝试导演，因为你太专业了，太有责任感了，你非常清楚一部作品是怎么制作出来的，并且能够为完成它所需的大批人员提供出色的领导。我只是……我超级崇拜你的能力。
Part of one right now. I will never back up into a start date, you know. Right, right. Yeah. Yeah. Lack of organization. And the script isn't ready. And then you're stuck there for three months.
我希望你能更多地坐上导演椅。我很乐意更多地坐上那个位置。我非常享受这个过程，而且我觉得……我很乐意看到你制作香肠（注：指导演作品）。对。恕我直言。从远处看，对。从远处看。
Stuck. Yeah. Yeah. Or so. This is why I always sort of push you into directing because you are so professional and you are so responsible and you are so aware of how the sausage is made and could provide great leadership for that large group of people it takes. I just, I'm just a big fan of your abilities.
我必须得说，难道你不觉得杰森的比喻棒极了吗？一包肠衣。太绝了。我常常纳闷他是从哪里收集这些比喻的，因为我知道他会把它们收集起来，然后再分发出去。那是一个小小的螺旋笔记本。皱巴巴的。对。
I hope that you jump into that chair more. I would love to jump into that chair more. I enjoy it thoroughly and I think it's. I would love to see you making some sausage. Yeah. Let me just, just for what it's worth. Just from a distance, yeah. From a distance.
你把它们存放在哪儿？就像藏在哪儿？对。难怪他的头发那么浓密。他的头发有多好？杰森的头发有多好？我知道。我们已经有好几期没聊这个了。
I do have to say, don't you love, Jason's metaphors are just fantastic. Pack of casing. They're incredible. I often wonder where he collects them because I know he collects them and then he distributes them. It's a little spiral book. Wrinkles. Yeah.
我太高兴我们又把话题扯回我身上了。好吧。不管怎样。我想问问这个，因为我觉得很多人在这个行业待了很长时间后，都会琢磨——天哪，威斯康星州的听友，我们指的是演艺界。继续说，肖恩。商业之树。
Do you store them? Like where are they? Yeah. That's why that hair is so thick. How good is his hair? How good is Jason's hair? I know. We haven't talked about it in a few episodes.
商业之树。商业之树。我们从这里面得到了很多，当然我们也付出了很多，但我们来到了一种类似十字路口的地方，我们会想：天哪，如果我能做点别的，我还会做什么？我能把这一切都抛在身后吗？因为很多人，就像我们在另一期节目里讨论过的那样，当演员们宣布退休时，我们觉得太棒了。
I'm so glad we're back to me again. Okay. So anyway. I wanted to ask about that because I think a lot of people when they've been in the business a long time kind of toy with, well, gosh, Wisconsin listener, we mean show business. Keep going. Sean. Business tree.
对吧？结果从来没真正退过。这就好像：永远别说你在戒烟，别……别宣布退休。千万别这么做。任何事都别。对。但如果必须选择别的，那会是什么呢？
The business tree. The business tree. That we've gotten a lot out of it and well, we put a lot into it too, but that we come towards a crossword kind of where we're like, gosh, if I could do something, what else would I do? And could I leave this all behind? Because a lot of people, like we were talking about before in another episode that we love when actors announce their retirement.
室内设计，大概吧。室内设计，你很擅长这个。对。你肯定很擅长。对。我太喜欢了。这是我的快乐源泉。对我和说这确实是个能让我快乐的地方。
Yeah. Right? And never do it. It's like, don't ever say you're quitting smoking, don't, don't see your retirement. Don't do that. Anything. Right. But what would that other thing be that if you had to pick something else?
你会为别人设计吗？你会不会有时候遇到朋友说：“嘿，你知道吗？我知道你没问过我，但让我来帮帮你吧。”我可不是那种人。不过我觉得……对。我也曾主动提出去帮别人，结果他们说：“过来帮我弄一下这个就行。”然后我说：“好吧，首先，那东西必须扔掉。”
Interior design, probably. Interior design, you're very good at that. Yeah. You'd be good at that. Yeah. I love it. It's my happy place. It's really a happy place for me.
然后他们说：“不，我不能扔。”我太喜欢这个了。这就是我丈夫。对。而这通常也就是我开始的地方，顺便说一句。那是杰森。因为通常情况就是这样。那是杰森。
Do you do it for other people? Do you ever like have friends who are like, hey, you know what? I know you didn't ask me, but let me help you with that. I'm not that kind of person. But I think it. Yeah. I've also offered help to people where they say, come over and just help me with this. And I go, well, first of all, that's got to go.
这就是问题所在。我能问你另一个普通人的问题吗？你不想让我再回到维基百科的话题上去了吗？你为什么不演《小妖精2》？是因为剧本吗？你对剧本不满意？我小时候可喜欢那部电影了。我太喜欢那部电影了。以后千万别在我面前说“当你还是个孩子的时候”，千万别。
And they're like, no, I can't. I love that. That's my husband. Yeah. Which is usually where I start, by the way. That's Jason. Because that's usually what happens. That's Jason.
好的。对不起。我们俩同岁。哦，对。没错。那是你拍的时候，对吧？15岁、16岁？不，我当时21岁。
That's the problem. Can I ask you another regular person question? You don't want me to go back into the Wikipedia stuff? Why didn't you do leprechaun too? Was it the script where you're not happy with the script? When I was a kid, I loved that movie. I loved that movie. Don't say when you were a kid ever to me again, ever.
哦，那没事了。年纪够大，该懂事了。你做过的最喜欢的工作是什么？你就会想，如果你回想起来，你会觉得：哦，天哪，我希望每份工作都像那样。我笑得那么多。我结交了一些朋友。我至今仍跟他们保持联系，巴拉巴拉巴拉。
Okay. Sorry. We're the same age. Oh yeah. That's right. That's when you made it, right? 15, 16? No, it was 21.
我经历过很多这样的工作。太多了。对。下一个问题。开玩笑。开玩笑。可能不止一个答案。
Oh, never mind. Smart enough to know better. What is the most favorite job you've ever had? You're like, if you think about it, you're like, oh my God, I wish every job could be like that. I laughed so much. I made some friends. I still connect, blah, blah, blah.
是的。我喜欢……很显然，那就是《老朋友》。这根本不用想。这绝对排在第一位，对吧？对。那全是家人。我必须说那是第一，那绝对是第一位。我一直很喜欢和桑德勒合作。
I've had a lot of them. So many. Yeah. All right. Next question. Kidding. Kidding. Might allow more than one answer.
对。他太有化学反应了，老兄。就顺其自然吧。超级好玩。我们在夏威夷拍摄的。所以这也是那次合作极其有趣的一半原因，而且，你知道的，我们从19岁起就认识了，所以……你和他合作过多少部电影？
Yes. I loved, well, obviously friends. That's a no-brainer. It's got to be number one, right? Yeah. That's all family. I would have to say that's number, that would be number one. I always loved shooting with Sandler.
我想说你和他合作过三部？两部。两部。两部，对吧？一部是《谋杀疑案》，然后就……就是那部？嗯。那就说得通了。那我这么问你吧。
Yeah. He's the dynamics man. Just go with it. It was super fun. We shot it in Hawaii. So that was half of why that was incredibly fun and, you know, we've known each other since we were 19, so. How many films have you done with?
很显然是《老朋友》。不过你还会再拍一部吗？你又要和桑德勒合作一部新片？嗯。太棒了。太棒了。听到这个真好。所以很显然《老朋友》是第一名，我们懂为什么，你们相处得那么好，而且在现实生活中你们仍然是朋友，这太棒了，所有那些人都非常优秀，就像杰森说的，这是一个大家庭。你拍过的最喜欢的电影是什么？让你感觉最……（我不是在贬低其他作品）
You've done three with him, I want to say? Two. Two. Two, right? One with the murder mystery, and then just that was it? Mm-hmm. So break it down. So let me ask you this then.
嗯。这倒不是给它们排名。更像是那段经历，以及你觉得它最终呈现出来的效果，还有你对它有多骄傲。
Obviously friends. Doing another one though. You're doing another one with Sandler? Mm-hmm. That's great. That's great. That's so good to hear. So obviously friends, it's like the number one, and we get it why, and you guys get along
我从那段经历中得到了什么。对，你从中学到了什么。对。我觉得你可以直接对着话筒说出来。那就太好了。有人非常明确地告诉我，只要……我们从她那儿收到了极佳的音量。我声音太大了吗？
so great, and you're all still friends in real life, which is so awesome, and all those people are really great people, and it's like Jason said, it's a family. What was your favorite film that you made that you felt the most, and not to disparage any of the other ones? Mm-hmm. It's not sort of like ranking them. It's more like the experience times, how you thought it came out, and how proud you were of it.
没有，我们听得非常清楚。因为我在这类节目里容易大喊大叫。是啊，你那个吸管杯用得怎么样了？对啊，肖恩，就好像话筒……他甚至都没法为了那个吸管杯把头往旁边移一下。就像是……你就像是在竞争。
What I got from the experience. Yeah, what you got from it. Yeah. I think you could just go ahead and speak it in the mic. That'd be great. I was told very clearly how far just. We're getting great level from her. Am I too loud?
就像水必须和话筒争夺进入你嘴巴的机会一样。我的天哪。听友们，肖恩面前放着一个巨大的话筒。他确实有。就像个动画片一样。就像个动画片。所以，珍，你最喜欢的是哪一部？你拍过的那部电影，让你觉得“就是它了”的是哪一部？
No, we're so good. Because I tend to scream on these things. Yeah. How is your sippy there going? Yeah, Sean, it's like the microphone is. He couldn't even move to the side for that sippy. It was like. You're like competing.
我必须说，就个人而言，那是电影《蛋糕》。哦，对。对。太棒了。尽管那部电影拍起来极其辛苦。你在那部电影里表现绝佳。绝佳。太棒了。
Like the water's got to compete with the microphone for your mouth. Like Jesus. Listener, Sean has a tremendously large microphone in front of his face. He does. It's like a cartoon. It's like a cartoon. So Jen, what was your, what was that favorite, though? What was that movie that you did that you were like, yes?
谢谢。太棒了。是的。非常、非常感激。那是一次在创作上极具成就感的经历，因为作为演员，我所有想象中自己完全会害怕、完全会演砸的事情……我都演得不赖。对。
I would have to say personally it was the movie Cake. Oh yeah. Yeah. It was great. Even though that was incredibly hard work. You were fantastic in that movie. Fantastic. So good.
我得说。有传言说续集《派》正在筹备中，这有什么真实的成分吗？呃-huh。呃-huh。顺便说一句，最好糊弄的观众，我最喜欢这些笑话了。肖恩是地球上最好糊弄的观众。我有时一天会给肖恩FaceTime两次，因为我会觉得：这个包袱太蠢了。亚历山大都没笑。
Thank you. So great. Yes. Appreciate it deeply, deeply. That was an experience that was creatively fulfilling because all of my, everything I imagined as an actor I would be completely afraid of and suck at. I didn't so bad. Yeah.
周围没人笑，但你知道谁听到这个会笑。太蠢了。不过等等，我想说，我想说，因为你现在已经在演艺界的各个领域——电影、电视以及其他所有领域——都体验过并取得了无人能及的卓越成就。虽然还不是音乐剧。还没演过音乐剧，但在《早间秀》里你唱得太棒了。我太喜欢了。我事后还给你发短信了。
I'll say. Any truth to the rumor that the sequel Pie is in the works? Uh-huh. Uh-huh. By the way, easiest audience, those are my favorite jokes. Sean is the easiest audience on the planet. I will FaceTime Sean sometimes twice a day because I'll be like, this is a dumb bit. Alexander's not laughing.
我说：哦，天哪，太棒了。但是你有没有想过……你怀念情景喜剧的拍摄日程吗？你还想再演一部吗？每天都想。每一天。这是有史以来最好的拍摄日程。真的。这是地球上有史以来最好的日程安排。
Nobody around here, but you know who's going to laugh at this. So stupid. But wait, I want to say, I want to say, because now you've experienced and excelled and like nobody's business in all areas of show business, movies and TV and everything else. Not musicals yet. Not musicals, but you sang amazing on Morning Show. I loved that. I texted you after.
所以你还会再拍一部。如果我知道能和当年那些家伙拥有同样的经历，是的，但我怀疑那样的机会永远不会再有了。对。不，不会再那样发生了。不过我记得我拍那个的时候，我们在拍吉姆·布罗斯的《米勒一家》。和吉姆·布罗斯。对。
I was like, oh my God, that was so great. But would you ever want to do, do you ever miss the schedule of a sitcom and would you ever want to do one again? Every day. Every single day. The best schedule ever. Really. It's the best schedule ever on the planet.
就像每个周末，我们都会……而你总是会说：哦，天哪——你简直迫不及待。我太嫉妒了。我也想去。我去片场参观过几次。你来片场参观过。对。那部剧里还有谁？
So you would do another one. If I knew it would be the same experiences I'd had with those guys, yes, and I doubt that will ever happen. Yeah. No, it won't happen that way. But I remember when I was doing that, the, we were doing The Millers with Jimmy Brose. With Jimmy Brose. Yeah.
除了你。你。哦，对了。你。肖恩。干得好，肖恩。我刚想说你长得太像那个演的人了。过来。
And like every weekend and we'd be, and you'd always be like, oh my God, like you just wanted to know. I was so envious. I wanted to be there. I visited the set a couple times. You came and visited the set. Yeah. Who else was on that show?
当然就是你。还有玛戈·马丁代尔。玛戈也在那部剧里吧？玛戈。玛戈·马丁代尔。爱了，崇拜。我们三个。
Well, with you. You. Oh, that's right. You. Sean. Well done, Sean. I was going to say you looked so much like the guy who did it. Come here.
我们笑得有多惨？她有多搞笑？我们笑哭了。她是那种能让你笑到哭的女孩。我其实跟她合作过另一部电影。哦，和史蒂夫·赞恩合作的《管理层》。又一个搞笑、非常有才华的男人。
It was you, of course. And Margot Martin. Wasn't Margot on that? Margot. Margot Martin. Margot Martindale. Love, worship. The three of us.
史蒂夫·赞恩。非常搞笑的家伙。哦。你把话题转向了一个情感层面的东西，我想。我想聊聊恐惧。哦，该死。哦，我太喜欢这个了。仅从……我们这里都是演员，我确信我们的许多听友也是——
How hard did we laugh? How fun is she? We laughed. I cried laughing. She's a cry, make you cry laughing kind of girl. I did another movie with her actually. Oh, management with Steve Zahn. Another funny, very talented man.
如果他们知道什么对他们好的话。但恐惧是如何在成功方面影响你的？在你获得成功之前，你的恐惧是什么样的？而在成功之后，现在的恐惧又是什么样的？你觉得……我想把这一切都归结为：你的成功已经稳固了，你是这个意思吗？不，你是一个如此慷慨、快乐、热情的人，你是个不可思议的演员，但那种状态是装不出来的。所以那是来自于一种安全感。
Steve Zahn. Very funny guy. Oh. You changed gear to an emotional thing, I suppose. I want to talk about fear. Oh, shit. Oh, I love that. Just speaking from, we're all actors here and I'm sure many of our listeners are not
那是一种没有太多恐惧的感觉，或者至少在某些领域那是健康的恐惧。这有什么变化吗？你一直都是这样吗？因为成功是一件非常复杂的事情。名气是一件复杂的事情。而不知何故，当许多达到你这种成功和名气高度的人变得不再信任他人时，你却设法保持了你那温暖、美妙、安全、信任的一面完好无损。实际上恐惧感会增加，但你似乎让自己免于陷入其中。
if they know it's good for them. But how fear affects you with respect to success and what was your fear like before you found success and what is your fear like now post-success? Like, how have you found, I guess I'm couching all this and your success is gone is what you're saying. No, you're such a generous, happy, warm person and you're an incredible actor, but you can't fake that. So that's coming from a place of security.
嗯，我觉得我们所有人都挺幸运的，我们在互联网和社交媒体出现之前就取得了成功。我觉得，我大概从来没有真正感到过恐惧。我不觉得我有过恐惧。我是说，我对其他不理性的事情有过恐惧，你知道的，比如，正如你所知的，坐飞机。你确实有。你讨厌坐飞机。哦，讨厌死了。
That's a place of not a ton of fear or at least it's healthy fear in certain areas. How has that changed? Have you always been like that? Because success is a really complicated thing. Fame is a complicated thing. And somehow you've managed to keep that warm, wonderful, safe, trusting side of you intact when a lot of people with your level of success and fame are not trusting. And actually the fear becomes increased, but you seem to have kept yourself from that.
为什么？因为它太重了，这不合常理。然而它却能离开地面。它飞起来，然后就停在空中。我知道所有这些大道理，但这很不理性。这是关于控制欲。我对坐飞机可一点恐惧都没有。为什么？
Well, I think all of us are kind of lucky that we found our success before the internet and before social media. And I think there was, I don't think I ever really had fear. I don't think I had fear. I mean, I had fear of other irrational things, you know, like, as you know, flying. You do. You hate flying. Oh, hate it.
嗯，我觉得我们所有人都挺幸运的，在互联网和社交媒体出现之前就取得了成功。而且我觉得，我好像从来没有真正感到过害怕。我觉得我没有恐惧。我的意思是，我对其他不合理的事情感到恐惧，你知道的，比如，正如你所知，坐飞机。你是的。你讨厌坐飞机。哦，太讨厌了。
Why? Because it's too heavy and it doesn't make sense. And yet it gets off the ground. It goes and then it stays there. I know there's all the things and I've been, it's irrational. It's control. I don't have any fear of flying. Why?
为什么？因为它太重了，而且不合常理。然而它却能离开地面。它飞起来然后就停在那里。我知道有很多科学解释，而且我去过，这很不理性。这是关于控制欲。我对坐飞机没有任何恐惧。为什么？
Why? You mean why? Because that big piece of metal going in the sky at 500 miles an hour, that's why, man. That's why. Yeah. And I've also had some pretty scary flight experiences, but anyway. But so those fears, I also was the one person to remember when we were on an airplane to a surprise trip for my birthday and we'd lost a wheel, I was the only one not afraid and
为什么？你是说为什么？因为那是一个以每小时500英里的速度飞上天的巨大金属块，这就是原因，老兄。这就是原因。对。而且我也经历过一些挺吓人的飞行体验，不过不管怎样。但是说到这些恐惧，我还是唯一一个记得这件事的人：当我们在飞机上飞往给我过生日的惊喜之旅时，飞机少了一个轮子，我是唯一一个不害怕的人，
everyone else's in tears writing emails and notes to their family. And I'm thinking. Did that surprise you? That you kind of clicked into a mother hand there and was strong for everybody? What I realized was, oh, just how irrational my fear is of flying because here we are in a moment where there could actually be something going terribly wrong and I have complete faith in our pilot. I have complete faith in what's happening.
其他所有人都泪流满面地给家人写邮件和便条。而我在想。这让你感到意外吗？你当时那种母性大发、为所有人坚强起来的状态？我意识到的是，哦，我对飞行的恐惧是多么的不理性，因为此时此刻，可能会有非常糟糕的事情发生，但我对我们的飞行员有百分之百的信任。我对正在发生的事情有百分之百的信任。
Right. And I'm not done, Sean. Sorry. Sorry. I get excited. I know I can see that. So my girlfriend, Dre and Kristen, we, the three of us, were like, we're not afraid. And Courtney, who is like her dad's a pilot, she's never afraid.
没错。而且我还没说完，肖恩。对不起。对不起。我太兴奋了。我知道，我看得出来。所以我的女友、德雷和克里斯滕，我们三个当时都觉得，我们不怕。而柯妮，她的爸爸是个飞行员，她从来都不怕。
Molly, Amanda, Amanda's like, I'm not going down on the plane, my dad. And so that's irrational. That was that insight into that. But in terms of the business, it takes a lot of work to maintain everything that you said because I don't want to ever lose that. I don't want to stop trusting people. And I see how it can happen. And I've had reason to.
莫莉、阿曼达，阿曼达的反应是，我才不会跟飞机一起坠毁呢，我爸他……所以这很不理性。那是对那种情况的一种洞察。但就事业而言，要维持你所说的一切需要付出大量的努力，因为我永远不想失去那种状态。我不想停止信任别人。而且我明白这是怎么发生的。而且我也有过理由。
I've had all sorts of not great things happen to me where your trust could easily be broken. But I'm not going to do it. Not going to do it. And so there's therapy. Right. But you seem to have taken the assets and the capital that Successor fame has given you. And instead of buying yachts and whatnot, you've actually taken that as an opportunity to,
我经历过各种各样不太好的事情，你的信任很容易就会被打破。但我不会那么做。我不会那么做。所以有心理治疗。对吧。但你似乎把“继承人”带来的名气所赋予你的资产和资本，没有拿去买游艇之类的东西，而是实际上把它当作一个机会，
when somebody approaches you, you get their best self, right? Because when they meet you, they're happy, they're in a good mood. They want to talk to you. They're asking questions. And you take that opportunity to actually put people at ease and bring them in and give them a good experience. And I just find that that's a really generous instinct of yours. And I suppose my question somewhere in all of this is how.
当有人接近你时，你能激发出他们最好的一面，对吧？因为当他们见到你时，他们是高兴的，心情是好的。他们想跟你说话。他们在问问题。而你抓住这个机会，真正让人们感到轻松，把他们拉近，带给他们美好的体验。我只是觉得你这是一种非常慷慨的直觉。我想我在这其中想问的问题是，怎么会……
Jason's question is, how could you do that? Because he could never do that. Yeah. Like, you just see it. Have you always been like that? Or was it something that you made a conscious decision where I'm going to take this capital and I'm going to take this sort of junk food confidence and actually switch it into something that can benefit my life and my friends and the people that come into my circle?
杰森的问题是，你怎么能做到这一点？因为他绝对做不到。对吧。就像，你一眼就能看出。你一直都是这样的吗？还是你做过一个有意识的决定，打算把这笔资本，把这种垃圾食品般的自信，实际上转化为能让自己、朋友以及进入你圈子的人受益的东西？
Because it's a nice thing. Junk food confidence. Another good one. Yeah. Junk food confidence. You know, when I was a little kid and we were at Joe Allen's, I don't know if anybody remembers Joe Allen's. Of course.
因为这是一件好事。垃圾食品般的自信。又一个好词。对啊，垃圾食品般的自信。你知道的，当我还是个小孩子的时候，我们在乔·艾伦餐厅，我不知道还有没有人记得乔·艾伦餐厅。当然。
That's in New York. In New York City. It's a big after-broadway dinner restaurant. After-broadway place. And I was there and there was a guy that was on Sesame Street in the restaurant. And I remember walking over to him at seven years old. I was seven. And I walked over to his table and I tugged on his jacket and he literally whipped his
那是在纽约。在纽约市。那是一个很大的百老汇演出后吃正餐的餐厅。百老汇演出后的去处。我在那儿，餐厅里有个出演《芝麻街》的人。我记得在我七岁的时候向他走过去。我当时七岁。我走到他的桌子旁，拉了拉他的夹克，而他简直是猛地
head around with fiery anger in his eyes and said, cookie, give me cookie. What did he say? No, honey. It was not a muppet. It was not a puppet. It was a human being. Okay. He burst into tears, basically was like, I'm having dinner and I didn't know any better,
转过头来，眼里带着怒火说：“饼干，给我饼干。”他说了什么？不，亲爱的。那不是布偶。那不是木偶。那是个人。好吧。他几乎要急哭了，大概意思是“我正在吃晚饭呢”，而且我当时也不懂事，
but that's not something that you do when someone's in the middle of dinner. So and there was a couple of moments. I also just know that that's something I don't want to be, these people are why we work. Right. So it was just a part of you. You've always been like that. And thank God for all of us.
但当别人正在吃晚饭的时候，你可不能那样做。所以有过那么几次经历。我也只是明白那不是我想成为的样子，这些人才是我们工作的原因。对吧。所以这是你的一部分。你一直都是这样。感谢上帝保佑我们大家。
Yeah. You know what I would say, Jen? Yes, honey. I would say the other thing though. I know that story about being on the plane and I also get nervous of flying and do you? Yeah, I do. I don't think I know that about you. Yeah.
对啊。你知道我会说什么吗，珍？什么，亲爱的。不过我会说另一件事。我知道那个在飞机上的故事，其实我对坐飞机也感到紧张，你也是吗？对啊，我确实是。我想我以前不知道你这样。对。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And then he's on the plane for almost a few years. He hates it. And he does the same thing I do, which is like, there's bumps and then you're like, why is everybody not paying attention?
对。对。对。对。而且他在飞机上待了几乎好几年。他讨厌这样。而且他做的事情跟我一样，就是当遇到颠簸时，你会想，为什么每个人都不理睬？
Yeah. Yeah. And everybody's so calm. And everybody's so calm. They're like, why are you relaxed? Like, I'll be watching a movie and then there's bumps and I flip it down and I'm like, I can't watch the movie. I'm like, looking around like, how can you watch the movie in this, you know?
对。对。而且每个人都那么冷静。每个人都那么冷静。他们会想，你为什么这么放松？比如说，我本来在看电影，然后遇到颠簸，我就把屏幕合上，心想，我没法看电影了。我就会环顾四周，心想，在这种情况下你怎么还能看电影，你知道的？
Whatever. Anyway, my point was... Do you ever feel that you go to the pilot or look to the whoever the person is on the to see if anybody else is panicking. Cause I used to look, I used to look to the flight attendants. Flight attendants, always. If they're calm and they're normal and they're just like holding on, then I'm fine.
随便啦。总之，我的意思是……你有没有觉得你会去找飞行员，或者看看飞机上不管是哪个人，想看看有没有其他人惊慌失措？因为我以前会看，我以前会看空乘人员。空乘人员，永远如此。如果他们很冷静，很正常，只是抓紧扶手，那我就放心了。
Always do that. And so, but what I was going to say was that your ability in that moment where the wheel falls off and it's like, holy shit, where most people would freak out. Whereas before most people in normal turbulence would not freak out and it's the reverse, right? All of a sudden, when there's a real issue, you're not freaking out.
总是这样做。所以，我要说的是，你在那个轮子掉下来、情况类似“卧槽”的时刻所展现出的能力——在那种情况下，大多数人都会吓疯。而之前在普通的湍流中，大多数人反而不会吓疯，这恰好相反，对吧？突然之间，当真正的问题出现时，你却没有吓疯。
And it really speaks to kind of what Jason, you were saying before about fear. Your fear of, you have a fearlessness in what you do. And that's what makes you so good at what you do. Because when the moment, you're so good at being in the moment all the time. And when the moment calls for it, and even if it's whatever, like you,
这真的很符合杰森你刚才关于恐惧所说的那些话。你的恐惧，你在做事时有一种无所畏惧的态度。这就是为什么你做事那么出色。因为当那个时刻来临，你总是非常擅长活在当下。每当时刻需要你这样做的时候，哪怕情况是怎样，比如你，
so there's a thing going that you have to deal with it. There's nothing you can do. You have to be in that moment. And I think that that really, it doesn't surprise me that you weren't scared in that moment. Right, because that's what I was gonna ask too, is Jen, don't you, when something like that happens, do you click into a different kind of mode
所以现在有事情发生了，你必须去处理它。你无能为力。你必须身处那个时刻。我觉得这确实——你在那种时刻不害怕，这并不让我感到意外。对，因为这也是我想问的，珍，当那种事情发生时，难道你不会进入一种不同的模式吗？
when like a crisis happens or something big happens, we're like, okay, I gotta take care of it, blah, blah, blah. That sometimes happens to me when, I look like I can't even get myself dressed in the morning. Yeah, but you do click in. I know what you mean, Shawn. Like she did like, remember the fires a couple of years ago and it got really close to your house
当危机发生或者大事发生时，我们会觉得，好吧，我得去处理它，巴拉巴拉巴拉。有时我也会这样，虽然我看起来连早上穿衣服都搞不定。对，但你确实会进入那种状态。我明白你的意思，肖恩。就像她那样，还记得几年前的那场大火吗，它离你的房子非常近，
and you were up on the roof taking those videos. Yeah. And we were all like, Jesus. And you're like, I know, look how close it is. And I was like. That was actually a scary moment. I had to get the dogs and I had to get in the car because no one could get up to the house either.
而你当时站在屋顶上拍那些视频。对。我们当时都觉得，天哪。而你说：“我知道，看它离得多近。”我当时就想……那确实是一个吓人的时刻。我得去把狗带上，还得钻进车里，因为当时也没人能上到房子那儿去。
Yeah, but you weren't flipping out in that moment, even though you did clear out for a few days, you weren't flipping out. No. Well, you've been handling a lot of responsibility for a long time, right? You're practiced at that. I'm my own, you know, it's me and me and me and me.
对，但在那种时刻你并没有抓狂，尽管你确实避难了好几天，但你并没有抓狂。没有。好吧，你长期以来一直承担着很多责任，对吧？你对这个很有经验。我是我自己的，你知道的，只有我和我，我和我，我和我。
Very self-sufficient. Yeah. Jen, I wanna know something. Who do you, because you seem to me to be so together and maybe it's the meditation, maybe it's just life experience, maybe it's just who you are. I'm not, I'm really not, I'm a hot mess.
非常自给自足。对。珍，我想了解一件事。你把谁当作……因为在我看来你总是那么淡定，也许是因为冥想，也许只是生活经验，也许这就是你的本色。我不是，我真的不是，我是一团糟。
But you do, you seem, so am I, I'm a hot or mess. But you do seem so together and so strong. Key word, seem. No, no, that I always. I'm an ice cold mess. Like, I feel like you're way more enlightened in a sense than I am or most people are because of the work that you've put in.
但你确实，你看上去……我也是，我是一团更大的糟。但你确实看上去那么淡定，那么坚强。关键词：看上去。不，不，我一直都是。我是个冷冰冰的一团糟。我觉得在某种意义上，你比我或者大多数人都要开明得多，因为你付出了那么多的努力。
And so who do you look to, because I sometimes look to you like, Jen, what do you do for this? And how do you think about this? And we just talked to each other a week ago and it was great about like advice about this certain issue. And so. What did she say, just put cream on it?
所以你把谁当成榜样？因为有时我会向你取经，比如：“珍，遇到这种事你怎么办？你是怎么看待这件事的？”我们俩一周前才刚通过话，当时关于某个特定问题的建议聊得特别好。所以……
I said, there's a salve for this. Yeah. But who is that, who is that for you? God, it's none of you guys. I've got great cream advice. I'm actually kidding. I find every, but every one of my friends has something wonderful to offer.
她当时说什么，直接抹点药膏吗？我说，这有药膏。对。但对你来说，那个倾诉对象是谁？天哪，你们都不是。我有很好的药膏建议。其实我开玩笑呢。我发现每个人，我的每个朋友都有美妙的建议可以提供。
I'm, oh, I mean. You're covered. I'm so covered. You are covered. I feel so covered. I mean, JB, I go to you for certain issues, topics, you know, well. Nothing.
我，哦，我是说。你被照顾得很好。我被照顾得太好了。你被照顾得很好。我觉得自己被照顾得无微不至。我是说，JB，有些问题或话题我会去找你，你知道的，嗯。什么都没有。
Do you go to JB for like box office stuff? Like tracking, tracking. Deadline, any kind of like, you know. Tracking ratings, stuff like that. But by the way, yes. Yes, no, I know. Who you go to for that? If there's any, it's like my own walking deadline.
你会为了票房之类的事去找JB吗？比如追踪，追踪数据。Deadline网站，还有任何那种，你知道的。追踪票房表现之类的东西。但顺便说一句，是的。没错，我知道。你为这事去找谁？如果有这种事，他就像我行我素的Deadline网站。
I'm not proud of that. Wait a minute, I'm not proud of that. Why? It's incredible. It's what you're known for. What do you mean? All you're known for. Well, I pay attention to what we do for a living.
我对此可不引以为傲。等一下，我对此可不引以为傲。为什么？这太不可思议了。这就是你的标志。你什么意思？你唯一的标志。好吧，我关注我们靠什么谋生。
Your nickname is Junkit, by the way. That's the adorable thing. Which I love. He loves a Junkit. I don't want any info sneaking up on me, you know? No, I agree. Jen, remember you did that? What was that thing you did with the rocks
顺便说一句，你的外号叫“小情报”。那是件很可爱的事。我很喜欢。他喜欢“小情报”。我可不想有什么内幕消息偷偷摸摸地找上门来，你知道的？不，我同意。珍，还记得你做过的那件事吗？你用石头搞的那玩艺儿是什么，
and we all had to write down like our thing that we loved. Everybody had to write their thing on the rocks about what they wanted or whatever. And then. An intention. What's the most important thing in your life? And you know what you wrote, Will, on your rock? What?
然后我们都得写下我们热爱的事物。每个人都得把他们想要的东西或者随便什么写在石头上。然后……一种意图。你生活中最重要的是什么？你知道你在石头上写了什么吗，威尔？什么？
My boys. And you know where that rock is? It's on my dresser. I took that rock and I put it on my dresser and I'm gonna send you a picture when I get back. Is that true? Yeah. You stole my rock?
我的男孩们。你知道那块石头在哪儿吗？在我的梳妆台上。我把那块石头拿走了，放在我的梳妆台上，等我回去后我要给你发张照片。真的吗？对。你偷了我的石头？
That's my rock. Those are my rocks. I think you said, yeah, you guys can take them with you if you want or something like that. And Will, I think you just walked away from it. And I was so warmed by your little rock, Willie, that I took it for you. Now I'm not gonna make my shot at you.
那是我的石头。那是我的石头。我想你当时说过，是的，你们如果想要可以把它带走什么的。威尔，我觉得你当时就把它留在那里走开了。威尔，你的小石头让我心里暖洋洋的，所以我就帮你拿走了。现在我可不会借机嘲讽你。
I'm not gonna take a shot at you because. If I had to write something that I wanted on a rock, what would it be? Whip cream. Cookies? Milkshakes. Milkshakes. Jennifer, Margaret, Jasmine, Aniston.
我才不会嘲讽你，因为……如果非要在石头上写下我想要的东西，那会是什么？鲜奶油。饼干？奶昔。奶昔。珍妮弗·玛格丽特·茉莉·安妮斯顿。
Incredible that you joined us. That is? That's how that goes. We've taken, we've actually, you've been more generous. Did we talk about anything? No, well, that's what this show is. Like, we're not interviewers, we're not bright, and we just have a conversation.
你能加入我们真是太不可思议了。是吗？事情就是这样。我们聊了，实际上，你更加慷慨。我们聊了什么吗？没有，好吧，这个节目就是这样的。我们不是采访者，我们也不聪明，我们只是在聊天。
Oh, stop saying that about yourselves. Don't talk about my friend like that. Yeah, well, it's smartless. We're living up to our title. Yeah. But you have been very, very generous with your time. Yes, thank you. Well, I love you all dearly.
哦，别这么说你们自己。别这么说我的朋友。对啊，这就是Smartless。我们没有辜负我们的名字。对。但你在时间上一直非常慷慨。是的，谢谢。好吧，我深深地爱着你们大家。
I love you very much. Love you. And thank you for all of the wonderful compliments. My God, this is the place to be. You need a little booster. Little booster shot, a little love bomb from my boys. We got plenty. We don't do it to everybody, so.
我也非常爱你们。爱你们。谢谢你们所有的美赞。天哪，这里真是一个好地方。你需要一点强心针。我这群好兄弟给你来点强心针，来点爱意炸弹。我们有的是。我们可不是对谁都这样的，所以。
No, you should hear some of them. We love you dearly, so much. Love you, honey. Love you so much. Love you too. All right, I'll probably see you in about an hour. Yeah, see you soon. Love you.
不，你真该听听他们对别人怎么说的。我们深深地爱着你，非常爱。爱你，亲爱的。非常爱你。我也爱你。好吧，我大概一个小时后就会见到你。对，待会儿见。爱你。
Love you. Love you. Bye. Okay, bye. Bye, love you. You know what? I like that Jen, she added the, which we could start.
爱你。爱你。拜拜。好的，拜拜。拜拜，爱你。你知道吗？我喜欢珍这一点，她加上了那个，我们可以开始了。
We should start kissing. No, no, no, we don't need to add that at all. No, we should start kissing. I do think that Bye did, may have started at her house. I mean, we didn't, we took it off of some sort of television show or film, because it's been around for a while, but. Yeah.
我们应该开始飞吻了。不，不，不，我们根本不需要加上那个。不，我们应该开始飞吻了。我确实觉得那个“拜拜”可能始于她家。我是说，我们没有，我们是从某种电视节目或电影里借鉴来的，因为它已经存在一段时间了，但是。对。
But yeah, I feel like I've heard that from her before. One of the great things about this age that we live in, say that, and we'll keep, this'll be on the show. And then in the comments, it'll be like, that did not fucking, it actually came from like, okay, man. That started on, say it by the bell, these sons of bitches. Yeah, Milliman, how dare you and appropriate my fucking expression by,
但是，是的，我觉得我以前听她说过。我们生活的这个时代最棒的事情之一，就是你说出这句话，然后我们会继续，这段会被剪进节目里。接着在评论区就会出现：“那他妈的才没有，它其实源自于……好吧，老兄。”那始于《救命下课铃》，这群狗娘养的。对，米利曼，你怎么敢挪用我他妈的表达方式，
and like, okay, man. I was the first person to put six E's on Bye. Yeah. I think it was welcome back, Connor, when one of the sweat hogs said, bye. Actually, it turns out I just looked into it. My uncle used to work at it, and I just, I have the proof, and I have the thing on YouTube,
并且说什么“好吧，老兄”。我是第一个在“拜”字后面加六个E的人。对。我想那是《欢迎回来，科特尔》，当时其中一个肥猪说“拜”。事实上，结果证明我刚查过。我叔叔以前在那里工作，我刚刚拿到了证据，而且我在YouTube上也有这段视频，
like, fuck off. Who cares about your fucking opinion? Shut up. We don't care. We're saying it, and now it's law. And you can shut up. Who get it, Will? Will's the police.
滚开。谁在乎你他妈的意见？闭嘴。我们不在乎。我们说了，现在它就是金科玉律。你可以闭嘴了。听懂了吗，威尔？威尔就是警察。
We're back in a Will's dinner hour here, you can tell. I know, I already had dinner. Guess what, you're not gonna be surprised I had cake for dessert. I'm sure you did. In celebration of Jen? In celebration, I didn't know there's Jen coming on. I didn't know it was him.
你可以看出来，我们又回到了威尔吃晚饭的时间了。我知道，我已经吃过晚饭了。你猜怎么着，我吃了蛋糕当甜点，你一定不会觉得意外。我猜你确实吃了。为了庆祝珍的到来？为了庆祝，我不知道珍要来。我不知道是她。
She was in the movie Cake. Oh, well, I can't, yeah, I can't, look it, it's exhausting explaining things to you. I can't be your go-to guy for everything that's... I'm gonna go celebrate the sequel and have a piece of pie right now. Yeah, see, I love it. I love it.
她演过电影《蛋糕》。哦，好吧，我不能，对，我不能，你看，向你解释事情太累了。我不能成为你任何事情的万事通……我要去庆祝续集，现在就去吃一块派。对，看吧，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。
I love you keep selling that joke. But Jason, thanks for bringing her on, because we're all friends with her. She is a light. There's a reason she's Jennifer Aniston and super, super famous and lovely, because she is real and normal and relatable and accessible. And she is...
我喜欢你一直推销这个笑话。不过杰森，谢谢你邀请她来，因为我们都是她的朋友。她是一个小太阳。她之所以是珍妮弗·尼安斯顿，而且超级超级有名又可爱，是有原因的，因为她真实、正常、接地气、平易近人。而且她……
Well, it's a tricky thing that we're all having to deal with too, right? Because we're having a lot of our friends on the show. We want to talk to them. I think some listeners want to hear from them. And but we like, for instance, Jen, perfect example. I know tons about her just personally. So like, I literally do have to go to the God damn
好吧，这也是我们大家都在面对的一个棘手问题，对吧？因为我们邀请了很多朋友上节目。我们想和他们聊天。我想一些听众也想听到他们的声音。但我们，比如珍，就是一个完美的例子。我私下里对她了解得太多了。所以，我真的必须去该死的
Wikipedia page to find out what the hell would I ask her that I don't already know. And it is an interesting piece of research that one has to do when you're inviting somebody on that you've known forever. We're dealing with that. Yeah, but it's also really fun because it can just be a shoot and a shit.
维基百科页面去查查，我到底能问她什么我还不知道的问题。当你邀请一个你认识了很久的人上节目时，确实需要做一件有趣的研究工作。我们在处理这件事。对，但这也真的很有趣，因为这可以只是一次闲聊扯淡。
Right, right, which is what it ended up being. And I don't know if it was worth listening to, but I loved it. But it is, you know, as Sean, like you said, like it's not always the case, but I think that we, as we've gotten older too, you kind of whittle down and you choose to spend the time with the people
对，对，结果也确实成了这样。我不知道这是否值得一听，但我是真的很喜欢。但正如肖恩你刚才说的，情况并非总是如此，但我认为随着我们年龄的增长，你会逐渐精简，你会选择把时间花在那些最真诚的人身上。我们三个花了很多时间跟很多类似的人在一起，没有抓马。珍就是那种人，她和你们两个都非常亲近，跟阿曼达也很亲近，非常亲近。多年来一直是这样，我和她也很亲近。那种感觉就像是，她是一个如此真诚的人。我们在节目里聊天的这个人，和你在一个小时后她家里聊天的这个人，
who are the most genuine and the three of us spend time with a lot of similar people and no drama. And Jen is one of those people and she's really close with you guys, both you guys and with Amanda, very close. And for years, and I'm closer with her as well. And it's that idea of like, she's such a genuine person. The person that we talk to here is the same person that you'll talk to at her house in an hour,
和三个月后在宣传通告上见到的这个人，和在夏威夷与亚当·桑德勒在片场合作的这个人，永远都是同一个人。而且她从来没变过。甜美、真诚、友善。我们应该邀请一个我们共同认识但我们都无法忍受的人。这是个好主意。
is the same person who's at the junket three months from now, is the same person who's on set with Adam Sandler in Hawaii, is always the same person. And it never changes. Sweet, genuine, nice. We should bring on somebody that we all mutually know that we can't stand. That's a good idea.
我向你们发起挑战，随便挑一个我们讨厌的人。我有人选。你有人选。我有。我有人选。一旦揭晓，我们就会知道了。我们会说：“哦。”
Somebody that I challenge you guys, just pick somebody that we hate. I got somebody. You got somebody. I do. I've got somebody. We'll know as soon as it's revealed. We'll go, oh.
等他一上节目，你们立刻就会知道。是个男的。我知道只要我把这个人请上节目，你们过后就会说：“卧槽。”你知道这让我想起了什么吗？你们有没有看过他们也试图翻拍过的一部电影？他们把它叫做《饭局秀》还是什么的？哦，《笨人晚宴》。
You'll know as soon as they come on. It's a guy. And I know as soon as I have this person on, after you're gonna be like, holy fuck. You know what this reminds me of? Did you ever see that they tried to do a remake too? They called it Dinner with Idiots or? Oh, Dinner for Schmucks.
《笨人晚宴》。但在法语里，我看过原版的法国电影，因为——当然，当然，因为你会说法语，巴拉巴拉巴拉。我们懂的。抱歉，我连想事情都用法语，真的很抱歉。但是，Dîner de cons，意思就是“笨人晚宴”，对吧？所以就是“蠢货”。
Dinner for Schmucks. But in the French, I saw the original French because- Sure, of course, because you speak French, blah, blah, blah. We get it. Sorry, I think in French too, I'm so sorry. But, so, Dine des Can, which is like the dinner for idiots, right? So Schmucks.
而这就是这个节目的样子。这有点像，谁能带来——整个过程就是在取笑他们，对吧？对，所以谁能，你必须这样做，那个游戏的目标就是带上最白痴的晚宴嘉宾。所以这就是这个节目的样子。我们必须带上最白痴的——
And that is what this will be. It's kind of like, who can bring- It's sort of made fun of them the whole time, right? Yeah, so who can, you have to though, the goal of that was that to bring the most idiotic dinner guest. And so that's gonna be this. We're gonna have to bring the most idiotic-
你们确定我们三个不是已经符合了吗？不，我们绝对是白痴。就像笑话已经应验在我们身上了一样，绝对的。我想我们都被邀请了。不，但你知道吗，不会是那样的。我们要带上的是这样一个人，因为没有时间去搞那些抓马之类的。而且这个人——还有少数几个人，虽然不多，
Are you sure it's not us three already? No, we're the idiots for sure. Like the joke's already on us, guaranteed. I think we all got invited. No, but you know what, it's not gonna be that. It's gonna be bringing on a person who, because there is no time for drama and all that. And it's somebody who, there are a few, not a lot,
但确实还有几个人完完全全就是混蛋。好吧，你知道我的理论，上次我也分享过了，无论你做什么工作，因为每份工作里总有一个混蛋，如果你环顾四周却找不到一个，那可能你就是那个混蛋。
but there are a few people left who are just dicks and they're just assholes. Well, you know, my theory is, and I shared this last time, whatever job you go on, because there's always an asshole on every job, if you look around and you can't find one, it's probably you.
这就是我们这一期的全部内容啦，各位。对，以高亢的音调结束，肖恩。这就是我们的主题。这实际上，确实是一个有趣的观点。好吧，她太棒了。我们爱她。真是个伟大的嘉宾，杰。
And that's our episode, everybody. Yeah. Way to go on a high note, Sean. That's our theme. That's actually, that is an interesting point. All right, well, she was great. We love her. What a great guest, Jay.
太棒了。简直就像一缕行走的阳光。没错。她真的是。好吧。爱你。拜拜。拜拜。
That was awesome. A little like just sunshine walking. That's right. She really is. All right. Love you. Bye. Bye.
是的。Smart. Loss。Smart. Loss。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Yes. Smart. Loss. Smart. Loss. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。精明。损失。精明。损失。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。